[Musica]
[Applauso]
e se vi dicessi che le crisi sono dei
momenti preziosi e che si può imparare
ad apprezzarle se ci si lascia andare
con tutto il cuore
se vi fidate di me tra poco vi farò
provare un senso di piacere legato ad un
esempio di crisi facciamo un esperimento
assieme supponete di essere un militare
in una missione nato in iraq in
afghanistan
eur no e se la tardi e cominciate a
sentire una certa sonnolenza
la7 e li distesi a terra seduti a
parlare con un collega sotto la luce
della luna piena ma guardate ieri era
stato un attimo sentite l'aria del
deserto sulla pelle vi chiudete gli
occhi riempite polmoni di quella reali e
per un attimo vi perdete nella
considerazione che la rifo e
meravigliosa anche se si è strappati da
casa
aprite gli occhi guardate un prodotto
guardate il vostro collega negli occhi e
sentite quello che mi sta dicendo mi
dice che vuole comprare una moto perché
quando vuole tornare a casa non vede
l'ora di correre per le strade di
collina
pensate che questa unità è una famiglia
le sorridete e poi accade un simile un
suono forte come se qualcuno avesse
cercato di strappare il cielo come si
strappa la carta e un'esplosione
non fate in tempo neanche sentire il
vuoto d'aria che vi si è creato nel
dentro qua non fate in tempo sentire le
vibrazioni che arrivano dai piedi ed
ecco un altro sibilo è un'altra
esplosione
è iniziata una crisi ora la cosa delle
crisi e che arrivano dal nulla sono
inaspettate e per quanto sia difficile
definire che cosa sono
sta di fatto che quando siede dentro una
crisi è chiaro non fate non fate
difficoltà a capirla
torniamo ad torniamo a prima vista noti
random là sopra tirano da sola il cielo
di sat alzati ricorsa state correndo e
in questo momento siete presi da un
sacco di emozioni contrastanti perché
avete paura avete il cuore in gola ma vi
sentite forti come non vi siete mai
sentiti
vi sentite concentrati e improvvisamente
come se qualcuno avesse acceso la luce e
ci vedete meglio al buio perché con come
se qualcuno avesse acceso la lampadina
la vostra vista si chiude come un tunnel
e tutto intorno si offusca siete
circondati dal caos in questo momento e
pensate alla vostra famiglia vi chiedete
se vedrete vostri familiari di nuovo vi
chiedete cosa accadrà ai vostri colleghi
che sono gli alla vostra unità che una
famiglia per voi in quel momento
respirate e cercate di reagire alla
paura pensate che normale avere paura
però pensate all'addestramento quindi
check check check e controllate
l'equipaggiamento controllate le armi e
siete arrivati correndo verso la vostra
unità
in questo momento il comandante riceve
informazioni da tutti sa cosa sta
accadendo
sa che sono arrivati di colpi chen diari
da degli ordini e voi ripetete di
ripetete per assicurare voi e per
assicurare le persone intorno a voi
perché sappiano che voi sapete che cosa
c'è da fare e quello che c'è da fare che
c'è da andare a prendere un collega che
è rimasto circondato dalle fiamme è
andate ora in questo momento il marasma
iniziale sono passati solo due minuti si
è trasformato in un caos controllato
perché sentire il concerto della
partecipazione di tutte le altre persone
mi fa sentire più al sicuro fa sentire
tutti più al sicuro e sentite che la
crisi inizia a svanire e arrivate dal
collega che circondato dalle fiamme
ora la lancia apre con l'acqua un
passaggio tra le fiamme e voi con
un'altra persona entrate dentro e andate
a cercare il vostro collega che era
abbandonato lì e
quando lo trovate paonazza sudato non
parla lo fanno gli occhi un solo sguardo
molto penetrante chi vi entra dentro e
vi dice tutto quello che non riesce a
dire dice avevo paura ma mi sono sentito
protetto ora ci sei tu che mi fido mi
stringe fortissimo però per poco tempo
perché momento andare però quello
sguardo non ve lo dimenticherete mai
perché in quel momento
essere la persona che andato a salvarlo
mi ha fatto capire per quel poco tempo
che avete appena creato un legame con
quella persona che più forte del legame
di sangue ma il punto è che quell
abbraccio
sono quei momenti con rapporto umano che
si crea quando si è superata la paura è
questa la parte positiva delle crisi
spesso lasciamo solo che ci rincuorano
ma ci dimentichiamo che
bisogna attraversare una crisi per
arrivare in quei momenti li per capire
quello che di buono possono portare e
per sentire cosa si provi veramente ad
essere umani
ora nel 59 l'allora senatore john
kennedy disse in un discorso che in
cinese la parola crisi è fatta da due
parole
pericolo ed opportunità ora anche se
senso comune che quell'interpretazione
non fosse corretta e ras al fatto che
quello che ha detto kennedy è vero e se
noi ci abituiamo solo a pensare che le
crisi siano dei pericoli che ci possono
distogliere dalla nostra attività ci
prendiamo perdiamo di vista quanta
positività ci possono portare e gli
esempi nella storia si sprecano
se prendiamo ad esempio la fuga di
petrolio che viene data dalla trivella
per prolifera deep water horizon nel
2010 fu probabilmente uno dei più grandi
disastri climatici della storia però il
sistema topo tacche o che venne
impiegato per contenerlo e anche la
capacità di installare a quel sistema a
quelle profondità vengono sviluppati un
tempo record pochi mesi oppure il
terremoto che avvenne in giappone a
fukushima nel 2011 portano la germania a
distaccarsi lo nucleare e dichiarare di
voler investire nelle risorse
sostenibili
cinque anni dopo il 30 per cento
dell'energia prodotta in germania che
era green ha poi per non parlare del
copit il covip ci ha fatto vedere come
l'inghilterra sia stata in grado di
costruire un ospedale con 4.000 posti
letto in quattro giorni e come i cinesi
sono stati in grado di sequenziare il
genoma del virus in tre settimane
sta tutto nel potere creativo che viene
generato dall emergenza
lasciamo andare tutte le altre priorità
e dedichiamo tutte le attenzioni tutte
le energie solo per un unico obiettivo e
sono facessimo tutti i giorni saremo de
vincenti ma quando dedichiamo tutte le
energie a questo riusciamo a trovare noi
esseri umani soluzioni eccezionali in
brevissimo tempo
soprattutto molto ricche perché sono
arricchite dalla
dal senso di ricchezza della diversità
dei punti di vista
di persone quindi io penso sì penso di
sì che le crisi che si tratti di
pandemie o che si tratti anche dei
semplici momenti di stabilità di coppia
siano dei momenti del quale si può
prendere però vanno saputi gestire
perché restano molto pericolosi cosa
serve per gestire una crisi
uno sarà un piano serve aver pianificato
prima serve sapere che cosa sta
accadendo
serve una buona dose di improvvisazione
servono spiccate doti di problem solving
e servi risolutezza perché le decisioni
prese nel problem solving devono essere
applicati in azione spregiudicata serve
comunicare perché tutti devono sapere
che cosa sta accadendo e cosa devono
fare e serve a riadattare spesso il
piano ma soprattutto serve non avere
paura
ora parlando di paura
che parlando di piano
ogni crisi porta con sé delle elezioni
ha presa ed è interesse di ogni
organizzazione sapere cosa è andato e
cosa non è andato in passato in modo da
poterle riapplicare alle crisi future il
punto è che le crisi non si affrontano
quando avvengono si affronta in pace si
affrontano prima quando non staccando
niente se analizzano tutte le crisi che
possono avvenire quelle che ci si
aspetta soprattutto quelle che non ci si
aspetta si studiano le traiettorie
system si studiano le conseguenze si
studiano i propri punti di debolezza per
cercare di capire come mitigarli quali
sono le risorse che mi servono cosa devo
imparare a fare per poterle affrontare
ora qualcuno l'ha già citato prima
hanno ufficiali insegnano fin da piccoli
che nessun piano per quanto perfetto può
resistere all'impatto col terreno ed è
vero perché appena mette piede sul
terreno battuto in fumo
questo non rende il piano inutile perché
lo studio che ci sta dietro è l'aver
studiato ogni variabile ogni cosa che mi
posso aspettare tutto quello che è
impensabile e quello che mi permette uno
di non avere paura e due di dominare le
variabili anche quando sono al top
dell'incertezza
ora
cosa deve avere un buon piano per essere
un buon piano numero 1 identifica i
punti critici essenziali per punto
critico intendo quegli elementi a quei
punti della mia organizzazione che sono
talmente delicati che se vengono toccati
mi impediscono di fare qualsiasi cosa
ad esempio l'attacco informatico buona
cry del 2017 ci disse che un punto
critico essenziale erano alcune piccole
vulnerabilità nel sistema windows xp
il covip ci ha insegnato che alcuni
punti critici essenziali sono i posti
letto negli ospedali ora per un
fornitore di servizi internet cosa sono
i suoi server e per una qualsiasi altra
organizzazione quali sono
poi identifica i punti decisivi all
industria cioè risponde due domande 1
cosa mi rende al sicuro 2 cosa devo
ridere il realizzare per sapere di aver
superato l'emergenza cioè cosa deve
avvenire perché io sappia che ce l'ho
fatta e quali sono gli abilitatori
chiave che devo avere per arrivare a
raggiungere quegli obiettivi
poi analizza obiettivi possibilità
ovvero mette a sistema le nostre
debolezze con gli obiettivi che vogliamo
raggiungere che abbiamo capito nel punto
prima questo ci permette di sviluppare
le nostre linee d'azione di sviluppare
un concetto di operazioni e di dare
responsabilità dei compiti alle unità
delle nostre dipendenze poi analizza
tutto quello che può andare storto ma
tutto tutto ora facciamo un esempio di
nuovo voglio andare al mare o al lago in
macchina con gli amici
e allora analizzo cosa può accadere cosa
succede se c'è una frana se fosse uno
pneumatico
se mi rubano il portafoglio cosa faccio
se l'auto diventa un transformer
levanzo tutte poi è ridondante cioè
quando abbiamo analizzato i nostri
obiettivi nostri punti deboli
quello che non può funzionare e
qualsiasi rischio mitica ogni rischio
allora supponiamo che io quando arriverò
al mare nonostante l'auto diventa
optimus prime
mi voglio addormentare sul mare mi mondo
dimette dal sole non mi voglio bruciare
allora mi sarebbe la crema quindi per
mitigare il rischio di dimenticarne la
ne metto un po vicino alla porta prima
di uscire me ne metto un po nel
cruscotto dell'auto me ne metto un altro
po dentro lo zaino e mi metto anche una
monodose dentro la tasca così sono
sicuro che non sa che non perderò mai
ora questo approccio alla mitigazione
del rischio sia si applica ad ogni
rischio che identifichiamo durante il
piano così il piano diventa una bella
lettura che ci tiene impegnati per tutta
l'estate sotto l'ombrellone da gennaio
da giugno ad agosto poi deve essere
conosciuto da tutti ma tutti
perché solo quando tutti i membri
dell'organizzazione sanno quali sono le
variabili i criteri di emergenza i
livelli di contingenza quali sono gli
obiettivi quali sono i loro compiti
solo allora questo permette di
improvvisare di prendere decisioni e
permette alla leadership che è una deve
essere una forte cristallina di dare
degli ordini che permettono di superare
la crisi
ora una delle cose che ho detto prima
che servono e che non bisogna avere
paura e l'abbiamo detto che serve un
piano serve la buona leadership serve
poter contare sugli altri ma non
dobbiamo avere paura questo dipende da
noi il lavoro che ognuno di noi deve
fare su se stesso e per questo vorrei
ricordare che la vita è come se come
queste navi quale la vita è un
equilibrio su delle onde passiamo da
delle creste quando va tutto bene a
delle valli quando va tutto male ma è
normale è un equilibrio il ciclo della
vita tutto scorre quindi sappiamo con
assoluta certezza che ad ogni momento di
gioia seguirà un momento di tristezza e
viceversa quindi non c'è niente di male
nel prepararsi per il momento peggiore
in assoluto se anche dovesse essere
momento della nostra morte
tutto scorre e questo porta un po di
gioia e un po di rabbia da in alpha mas
diceva di un argento mentre dal gold
nate waves of aging sta inoltre light
non andare docile in quella dolce notte
ma rabbia rabbia
contro l'andare della luce
e dico che il modo migliore per
affrontare il cambiamento non è
resistere meda con esso
ora vorrei chiudere con una
considerazione ho accennato prima
lavorerai tirarla cioè che dobbiamo
restare tutti uniti
nel bel mezzo di una crisi ci sta e
comprensibile che venga un po automatico
pensare solo a se stessi ma non esistono
i supereroi
una persona non cambia il mondo una
squadra si è
ora tutto quello che ci circonda e che
diamo per scontato dalla nostra libertà
questo bellissimo paese in cui viviamo
il piatto caldo che abbiamo tutti i
giorni non viene dal cielo ci è stato
dato da qualcuno che l'ha siglato col
sangue per noi prima di noi e adesso
turno nostro e in mezzo a una crisi
dovremmo sostenerci darci supporto
dovremo aiutarci a vicenda perché solo
quando a milioni riusciremo a essere
compatti ea poter dare fiducia nel fatto
che potremo contare l'uno sull'altro che
potremo dare fiducia al fatto di poter
superare a qualsiasi cosa
ed e solo allora che potremo guardare
indietro momenti brutti come questo e
considerarli come dei momenti bellissimi
senza i quali non saremmo arrivati a
quel punto e potremo fare qualsiasi cosa
affrontare qualsiasi pandemia affrontare
il cambiamento climatico aiutare il
medio oriente aiutare milioni di
rifugiati che fuggono dal loro paese
ogni giorno
vorrei chiudere dicendo
che non dovremmo mai aspettare che
arrivino a crisi per costruire un piano
b ma dovremo farci trovare pronti prima
compatti tutti uniti perché sia solo
momento per apprendere migliorarsi
grazie
[Applauso]